i googled the deadliest animals in the
world
and uh humans were number two
number one mosquitoes are number one
exactly
but humanity um
is
right up there with the deadliest people
who killed the most animals in the world
mosquitoes number one
uh you know
malaria and everything that happens with
that but humans number two
being that you're such an animal lover
and you know you care about the
environment you care about animals and
you care about the world what are your
thoughts on what we can do as humans to
do better
love each other
we got all this quote tupac
we got all this money for wars but we
can't feed the poor the [ __ ] is going on
you know so much corruption so much
ill will towards other people you know
why are we in war in 2022
really
come on man
why make them so much money and you know
the thing is it's like
we're declining as a
morality of a species our morals are
declining as humans
i'm here to defend the mosquitoes
mosquitoes are number one deadliest
animal on the planet because they're
transmitting human blood to other humans
the mosquitoes ain't got [ __ ] to do with
it it's our nastiness that's making them
number one we're number one we are the
plague we gotta fix ourselves we gotta
adapt to life on earth and going against
each other isn't the answer to the
problem you know we got to find a
different solution to cohabitate
co-exist with everybody else on the
planet including the animals
there it is love each other i love you
bro you love each other i love you too i
love you guys you know no matter your
skin color where you're from what you
believe in your political views it don't
that [ __ ] don't matter
you know i'm best friends with a muslim
and a christian and a buddhist you know
or an atheist it don't matter we're all
seven billion people we're all different
we're never gonna ever be the same from
the start of time from adam and eve to
the end of time none of us never gonna
be the same so why are we continuing to
fight over what we believe and what we
don't if someone else got oil or gas or
resources talk to them don't just go
over there and take it if the economy is
going down and you're the government and
you're a part of it and you're not
helping the people that are from your
country the people that are born and
raised there
shame on you but they need to be held
accountable for that [ __ ] you know
people like elon musk said hey
i got
billions of dollars if someone said
you know x amount of millions save and
cure world hunger he goes show me the re
i'll give them the money and show me the
receipts yeah show me the math exactly
you know they'll do it they ain't going
to do it because they're going to get
that money they're going to put in their
pocket
and all people are going to be starving
still you know again we got money for
war but we can't feed the poor